Kiki das kannst du besser Langosch wie
vom
Weihnachtsmarkt ist doch gar kein
[Musik]
Problem hallo meine Lieben heute machen
wir ein ultra leckeres Rezept und zwar
kennt ihr das wahrscheinlich alle vom
Weihnachtsmarkt oder von der Kirmis wir
machen langorch das ist so ein leckeres
Rezept Leute es ist einfach frittierter
Teig mit richtig viel Knoblauch und
Schmand und Käse Schnittlauch oh mein
Gott mir läuft das Wasser im Mund
zusammen und ich würde mal sagen wir
fangen jetzt direkt an mit dem Rezept so
der Hefeteig besteht aus ganz wenigen
Zutaten und geht auch sehr sehr einfach
ich binute ein bisschen faul und benutze
meine Küchenmaschine und ich schreib
euch alle ganz genau Mengenangaben wie
immer unten in die Infobox ich gebe
jetzt hier erstmal Milch in die Schüssel
also eigentlich erstmal die flüssigen
Zutaten Milch Wasser beides ist jetzt
lauwarm die Butter habe ich in der
Mikrowelle zerlassen bei geringer
Wattzahl wenn das so ist müsst ihr da
immer die Reste noch rausschaben das ist
so viel und das macht wirklich was am
Gott bin so unvorbereitet das macht
wirklich was an der Konsistenz aus so
einmal da rein je nachdem welche Hefe
ihr jetzt verwendet müsst ihr schauen
bei frischer Hefe einfach in der lau
Milch mit ein bisschen Zucker auflösen
und dann damit reingeben und bei
Trockenhefe mache ich es jetzt so dass
ich einfach hier mit reingebe und da
kann man das auch noch so ein bisschen
vermengen muss man jetzt aber nicht
zwingend und das kommt jetzt hier mit
rein und da dann einfach nur noch Salz
und Zucker dazu geben und dann richtig
schön kneten lassen bis der Teig total
geschmeidig wird das dauert in der
Maschine wirklich nur ein paar Minuten
ansonsten wie gesagt könnt ihr das auch
mit den Händen
machen so der hefetig sieht super
geschmeidig aus nehme ich ihn raus oh ja
der fühlt sich richtig gut an ich Form
jetzt ganz grob jetzt ein noch zu einer
Kugel und dann muss er gehen gelassen
werden bzw ruhen gelassen werden 60
Minuten und dann geht er noch mal schön
auf weil longos ist ja bekannt dafür
dass es dann beim Frittieren zwar außen
richtig knusprig ist aber innen muss er
dann schön luftig sein und dafür
brauchen wir jetzt einfach die ruhzeiten
und da gebe ich jetzt einfach ein
bisschen Öl noch in meine Schüssel Teig
rein bisschen Öl noch oben drauf und
dann schön luftdicht an einem schön
warmen Ort am besten nicht bei Durchzug
aber wie gesagt an einem schön warmen
Ort ruhen lassen und dann sehen wir uns
gleich
[Musik]
wieder
die Langosch habe ich jetzt so geformt
sag mal eigentlich die Langosch ich weiß
es nicht ihr könnt weißt du es die
langosche schreibt mir mal gerne in die
Kommentare ich habe keine Ahnung auf
jeden Fall ich weiß wie es funktioniert
und wie es schmeckt und das ist jetzt
hier die Hauptsache ich habe jetzt auf
jeden Fall ein teling immer mal so
geformt dass man so ein kleinen dicken
Rand hat als auch nicht so übertreiben
aber das ist halt so die typische Form
und als Tipp das muss jetzt nicht sein
aber als Tipp könnt ihr das auch auf
Backpapier direkt ausbreiten denn ihr
könnt das Backpapier einfach ins Fett
gleiten lassen zum Fett habe ich aber
auch noch ein paar Tipps für euch weil
ich z.B ich habe einfach keine Friteuse
ich habe allen möglichen Kram aber sowas
nicht aber ich brauche das eigentlich
auch nie weil ich habe hier meine Pfanne
die ist auch ein bisschen tiefer und da
habe ich jetzt ein bisschen Fett
reingegeben viele machen noch immer viel
zu viel Fritierfett rein das braucht ihr
gar nicht weil es wird sowieso nur an
der Oberfläche schwimmen und dann dreht
man das um dann wird es von beiden
Seiten frittiert jetzt gebe ich hier
meinen
Holzstab rein da könnt ihr auch ein
schastiegspieß oder ein Zahnstocher
nehmen das was ihr gerade da habt und
wenn die Bläschen schnell hochsteigen
dann ist das Fett schön heiß und genau
richtig zum Frittieren wenn ihr merkt
die Blasenstein gar nicht auf oder viel
zu langsam dann ist das Fett auf jeden
Fall noch zu kalt und wenn du so richtig
brodelt wenn ihr das reintut dann ist es
zu heiß und jetzt heißt es nicht dass
ihr jetzt immer auf der gleichen Stufe
bleiben könnt bei Herd ich war jetzt
beim Erhitzen auf Stufe 8 bzw 9 von ne
bin jetzt aber auch wieder runter auf
Stufe 4 gleich kommen jetzt die ich sag
mal jetzt nicht kalten aber die Zimmer
war Teiglinge rein dann wird das Fett
auch noch mal beeinflusst also immer
wieder ein Holzstab nehmen reinun gucken
ob ob das Fett auf Temperatur ist und
auch gerne zwischendurch mal einen neuen
Holzstab nehmen weil wenn der irgendwann
vollgesaugt ist mit Fett dann
funktioniert dieser Trick auch nicht
mehr so jetzt gebe ich das hier einmal
rein könn richtig reingleiten lassen und
dann einfach an einer Spitze das
Backpapier noch festhalten und dann
könnt ihr das ganz einfach
[Musik]
lösen pro Seite braucht ihr wirklich nur
eine Minute 20 also es kommt natürlich
auch immer auf auf euren Topf an bei mir
wird ja die Wärme extrem gespeichert
deswegen brauche ich da jetzt nicht so
lange schaut aber auf jeden Fall mal
wirklich so nach eineer Minute 10eh wie
es aussieht sie müssen so richtig goldig
braun sein wenn ihr mal so helle Stellen
habt ist das kein Problem es ist
komplett durch es ist innen fluffig und
außen extrem knusprig und jetzt habe ich
ja hier schon mal meinen Schmand
vorbereitet und ihr könnt das jetzt nur
ganz kurz ein paar Minuten auskühlen
lassen aber noch warm genießen so
schmecken die echt am besten jetzt gebe
ich den nämlich einmal ich nehme hier
schon mal ein in die
Mitte und ich habe da echt so Bock drauf
schon seit Wochen habe ich mir gedacht
komm jetzt gönne ich mir das und zeig
euch direkt das Rezept so da darf man
auch nicht geizen und dann habe ich noch
Käse da könnt ihr euch entscheiden nimmt
ihr jetzt feterkäse nimmt ihr emtaler
ich habe jetzt Gauda genommen sieht man
das so ich ma mir mal hier den Weg frei
und da einfach den Käse oben drüber
reiben und der schmilzt dann auch noch
mal in der Resthitze oh ich habe so Bock
drauf Leute so und da drüber kommt dann
noch Schnittlauch wenn ihr möchtet oder
petasilie oder andere Kräuter und dann
ist unser Langosch auch schon fertig
boah sieht das nicht gut aus oh ich habe
das so Bock drauf gerade können wir den
tastest vorziehen ich beiß jetzt direkt
rein oder kom zieh vor mach einfach
egal oh mein Gott Leute das schmeckt so
gut bitte macht es nach das schmeckt es
ist Traum es ist ein 12 von ze bitte
macht das unbedingt nach schmeckt Hammer
lecker ich ich spreche jetzt nicht voll
Mund ich esse jetzt erstmal in
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Ruhe jetzt denkt ihr euch wahrscheinlich
ja langoschteig es ist ja ein herzhaftes
Rezept aber ihr könnt auch süß belegen
und wie geil ist bitte die Kombination
jetzt mit kiky scamers nougur ein
bisschen Werbung an der Stelle aber die
ist auch echt genial die ist ohne Palmöl
und mit guten haselnusskern also richtig
lecker die meisten haben sie jetzt auch
schon zu Hause ihr könnt mir aber gerne
auch mal jetzt reinschreiben welche
cream euer favorite ist und dann freue
ich mich von Euch zu lesen Leute das
nicht es ist ein Traum es ist einfach
ein Traum ich sag wie es ist ich gön mir
jetzt auch noch mal für euch ist
eigentlich gemein dass mein voresse nein
oder ihr könnt ja ganz einfach
nachmachen
kan man
rangehen heute ist so ein richtiger
gönnertag das schmeckt so lecker ich
kann es gar nicht beschreiben es ist
nicht es schmeckt nicht wie ein Donut es
schmeckt nicht wie was friittiert man
denn noch Berliner oder so es ist ganz
anders ihr müsst es einfach mal
ausprobieren Leute und ja ich entlasse
euch jetzt aus dem Video damit ihr das
ganze nachmachen könnt und sage bis zum
nächsten mal auf meinem Kanal und lasst
ein kostenloses Abo da dann verpasst ihr
nämlich meine Rezepte auch nicht mehr
und was ihr auch gerne machen könnt wenn
ihr noch irgendwas im gedch
was ihr vom Weihnachtsmarkt oder von der
chemis kennt und was ich noch nicht
abgefilmt habe dann schreibt es mir
gerne und ich ma das für euch also bis
zum nächsten Mal tschüss so bist du
ready für tasty testy ja alle ruhig sein
Rig also ehrlich das Ding ist kalt muss
warm gegessen werden eigentlich schon es
ist bisschen her aber ist schlimm
bisschen du weiß ja genau aber es riecht
krass was
istting das ist sch mit Knoblauch also
Date hab be nicht mehr trotzem voll weiß
ja ne es müsste jetzt richtig schön
luftig sein in drin und ausnusprig zeig
mal ich mal
daran ich muss sagen auch weil es gerade
weil es kalt ist ich das übertrieben
lecker also ich will g wissen wie ist
wenn es warm ist das war Abriss als es
warm war ich bin gestorben das war so
lecker kann man Mik ja klar ganz gerade
das na Hause zu nehmen wieder und die
Mikro ja kannst du machen aber so heftig
boah
mega point 10 von danke
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schön